today on the matt walsh carcass
yesterday's january 6th festivities were
as insufferable as expected we'll take a
look at some of the uh the highlights
and lowlights and we'll also compare
january 6 to the blm riots of 2020 to
see if we can determine which was worse
because it's not hard to do because
really there's no competition here at
all
also nancy pelosi told one of the most
egregious lies we've heard from a
politician
in quite some time which is saying
something and russia has a plan to stop
pedophiles
and that is to ship them off to penal
colonies in the arctic could we learn
something from that strategy plus we we
now know what online shopping in the
metaverse might look like and it's as
dreary and dystopian as you might expect
and morgan wallen survived his
cancellation attempt and went on to have
the number one best-selling album across
all genres last year so why am i
canceling him anyway well i'll talk
about that and much more today on the
matt walsh
[Music]
you know yesterday was a difficult time
i think for all of us you know the the
the tragedy of january 6th
is it's not just what happened which was
horrible and horrific and quite easily
the most tragic event in the history of
western civilization but but but even
worse are the fears you know of what
might happen next and these are fears
felt by everybody of all ages and i know
from experience and in fact last night i
was putting my seven-year-old pangender
child
sundance down to bed and uh as i was
turning off the light
they looked at me right in the eye and
they said matt
we're on a first name basis of course
um they said matt
what happens if there's another january
6th
will our democracy survive
and i paused for a moment and i thought
about it
and then i looked
them right back in the eye and i said
my sweet child
democracy is already dead
we're doomed
and they burst into tears and so did i
and we just held each other and sobbed
for hours it was a it was a terrible
moment but but also a beautiful moment
in a certain way um in any case
yesterday was january 6th
as you were probably reminded
one or two or maybe you know 97 times
it's kind of difficult to transition
into a more straightforward conversation
about this topic when i start decided to
lead off with a fake story about my
pan gender child name sundance but we're
already off to the races so let's just
keep going now the central point i want
to make here is
actually not about january 6th at all
but before we get to that point i do
have to review i feel like i must review
a few of the cringiest episodes
yesterday during the the left's january
6th festivities
it was destined already to be the most
insufferable day in american history
and i think it certainly lived up to
that billing so kicking off right away
with camila harris delivering a somber
address in remembrance of that day while
drawing direct comparisons between
a bunch of dummies trespassing in the
capital and pearl harbor listen
fellow americans good morning
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly remind
all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place
in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021.
there you go pearl harbor 911 i mean i'd
say that almost basically exhausts the
list of bad things in history that the
average leftist is aware of
there there is one other she didn't
mention though
and that is the holocaust
but surely surely surely nobody would
ever be so egregious so utterly without
shame
as to actually compare january 6th to
the holocaust
surely nobody would do that you might
insist
and you would be wrong
dwight eisenhower during world war ii
made sure all the holocaust camps were
filmed so we've got the film footage so
now we're combating conspiracy theorists
deniers
and some um and you know trumpeteers
but
my worry is what do we call this and
make sure we we honor this day this dark
stain day every year so we've got to
keep saying january 6th i think it is
like december 7th pearl harbor it is
like the 9 11 um tragedy and we also
need to not be afraid to call it the
trump insurrection of january 6 because
in the end all roads to what went wrong
that day lead to donald trump's ill
behavior his
anti-democratic stance he took the big
lie
after the presidential election tallies
came in and joe biden had won by
millions of votes
well now that we have that base covered
with all of the overwrought historical
analogies um what we need next are of
course the inspirational musical
performances unfortunately lin-manuel
miranda and the cast of hamilton they
were on hand well they were on zoom
anyway
um
not not wearing masks which i thought
was very reckless and they were there to
serenade members of congress with a
rendition of whatever the hell this song
[Music]
you
is
i fall apart
and i thought i was so smart
my father wasn't my
i swear father i'll be around for
you
i'll do whatever it takes
[Music]
we'll make it right for you
if we lay a strong enough foundation
[Music]
and that was followed of course finally
by the requisite um candlelight vigil
and the somber and this time masked
performance of god bless america
[Music]
america
my home
sweet home
[Music]
god bless
[Music]
by the way if you're wondering what
using the lord's name in vain looks like
or sounds like it's it's that that's
what it sounds like
it doesn't actually mean using the
lord's name that doesn't actually mean
using a phrase like damn in fact god
does damn things and there's nothing
wrong necessarily with pointing that out
if i were to say that i'm that i'm i'm
tired of of
damned gender theory being taught in
schools
which i am
and it is
that's not taking the lord's name in
vain because gender theory is a damned
and damnable thing
but um there we have people singing the
name of god
in an empty
and manipulative way purely for
theatrics to score political points
that's what taking his name in vain
sounds like okay
but i digress
there is i think one fundamental point
that needs to be made about all of this
and here it is
january 6 2021
was a time when a group of useful idiots
did something very stupid
something that had zero chance of
producing any positive result whatsoever
positive for them any with it there was
nothing positive that could possibly
come out of it for them
them personally um politically
anything
and in doing that
those useful idiots provided ammunition
to the left
which the left will never stop using
ever
in fact as annoying as all this
pageantry is
it's almost pointless to complain about
it
because of course the left is going to
do this
sure the whole routine is cynical and
absurd
but what else do you expect them to do
a bunch of right-wing dummies rioted at
the capitol do we expect the left to say
hey you know what let's not make a big
deal out of this
let's just move on guys
is that what we expect them to do no
only republicans are stupid enough to
refuse a gift when their enemies hand it
to them
democrats are are going to make hay
that's what they do
if you give them lemons they make
lemonade if you give them lemonade
to begin with then they'll just say
thank you and they'll sip from it
gratefully and repeatedly forever
it might not be honest or right morally
but it's smart politics
and and that's what they're doing with
january 6th
that's why when i look at what's
happened and how the narrative has
formed i look at you know what happened
yesterday
i'm not nearly as angry at the democrats
as i am at the republicans
democrats again are using the ammunition
that they've been given
the hapless republicans will whine about
it but rather than whining they should
be doing the exact same thing with the
blm riots
all of the time
that the democrats spend talking about
january 6th
republicans should be spending the exact
same amount of time talking about the
blm riots and in that case it would not
be dishonest or cynical because unlike
january 6th the blm riots of 2020 were
in fact an assault on our way of life
our civilization
um uh our democracy if you like
they were deadly
they were actually deadly they were
catastrophic they were unthinkably
tragic
and they were supported every step of
the way by every elected democrat in the
country
explicitly supported
the blm riots resulted in 25 deaths
dozens of injuries
two billion dollars of damage across the
country
they sparked a crime surge that still
hasn't died away
they were several several orders of
magnitude worse than january 6th worse
in every way by every conceivable metric
okay
they had exactly the destabilizing
effect on our system that january 6th
allegedly had but didn't really have
it's not a coincidence that crime is
running rampant in many of the cities
where these riots occurred the criminals
learned that they could get away with
this kind of thing they could get away
with violence arson looting and so on
and they've taken that message to heart
the blm riots therefore have a lasting
impact and a relevance that january 6
does not have
nobody is it's not like there are going
to be more riots at the capitol nobody
is ever rioting at the capitol ever
again okay that much is guaranteed
the people who took part in in that
are paying dearly for it
paying much more dearly than they should
actually according to how the law is
written they're being overcharged but
the blm riots rioters have paid almost
no price at all
so they've learned the exact opposite
lesson
this is why the blm riots represent an
ongoing existential threat in a way that
january 6 does not
and never did and never could it never
will
and while most people on the right
condemned january 6 while it was
happening i mean almost everybody did
except for the people that were there in
the building
everybody else said this is you
shouldn't be doing this like obviously
you should be riding at the capitol
um
but that hasn't happened on the left on
the left most people supported blm and
still do to this day
without apology
see this is not what about ism just to
be clear
bringing up blm is not what about ism
bringing up january 6th is what about
ism
because that is the irrelevant thing
used to distract from the more important
thing
and this is a point that republicans
could make
and they could keep making
over and over again
they could have candlelight vigils for
the officers killed or injured by blm
they could have days of remembrance they
could have memorial services
they could give speeches
you know they could make sure that
nobody ever forgets the date
when retire retired police captain david
dorn was shot in cold blood by a blm
militant during a riot
or the date when blm militants invaded a
police station in minneapolis and burned
it to the ground while the officers ran
for their lives
republicans could do that
but they don't
i mean they could talk about it
incessantly constantly so that nobody
ever forgets and that each democrat
responsible for encouraging it is held
responsible branded with it
has to wear it around their necks for
life
they could do that
but they don't
because they are feckless hapless
incompetent and scared
what else is new
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
as i'm sitting here in my car um now's
probably a good time to tell you about
an app that you all need to get if you
haven't gotten yet get upside with get
upside my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back
on your first fill up 25 cents cash back
on every philip after that don't pay
full price of the pump anymore get cash
back using get upside just download the
app for free and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two or three
hundred dollars a month in cash back and
there's no catch okay it's very simple
the cash is added to your account
and uh there's no red tape no hoops you
got to jump through you can cash out any
time to your bank account paypal you can
get an e gift card from amazon and other
brands so just download the free
getupside app and use promo code walsh
to get up to 50 cents a gallon cash back
on your first tank that's code walsh
all right we're still in the car um
you would never know that this is one of
the top political podcasts in the
country
based on the fact that i'm you know in a
car
and also based on the very poor quality
of the podcast in general in terms of
the content um
and i might be here for a while at this
point we got i would say we got like
eight or nine inches of snow
out out here and um that means that
we'll be snowed in probably until march
because because they don't do anything
have i complained about this before i
think i have um well you're going to
hear it again because here in tennessee
when there's snow on the ground they
don't do anything for it they don't they
don't break they don't send a plow out
on the road they don't treat the roads
they don't put salt down they don't do a
damn thing
so they're the people that run the city
in nashville their message to the
population is well oh there's snow on
the ground well it's like
i guess just stay in your house until it
goes away
you know wait we got the sun in the sky
they'll the sun will take care of it
eventually
now the claim that because when i got
here last year for the first winter in
nashville and um
and it snowed
and the roads were unusable
for a week and a half because they
didn't plow any of them and that
happened and i complained about it then
and i was told that well this doesn't
happen often enough um
for you know to to keep this in the
budget like it's not worth the money to
have plows and salt trucks and
everything because we don't get this off
enough well really
because this is my second winter here
and this is the second snowstorm we've
gotten
so how often does it need to happen for
it to be worthwhile and how expensive is
it really to have a couple of plows and
some salt trucks
i bet you okay let me take a look at the
budget here at the city of nashville let
me take a look at what they're spending
money on and i bet you i could find
money in the budget for some plows and
salt trucks i bet you i could
i mean we could start with i you know
i'm sure they have diversity consultants
and equity consultants and everything
and tolerance and inclusion uh experts
and everything they've got them on the
budget i'm sure so let's start there get
rid of them
get rid of all the diversity consultants
and replace them with plows and salt
trucks and we could start there
um that's the negative part of the snow
the good part is that uh i did frolic
and play in the snow yesterday joyously
as i promised as joyous as i get anyway
actually i thought this was a pretty
good parenting moment for me pretty
inspirational um so check this out you
know i look at the we have the video
here i wanted to go sledding with my
daughter as i said
and uh we were about to slide down the
hill
but then as you can see i re i realized
that she was weighing me down because
the snow's really powdery and we hadn't
made a track yet for the sleds and she
was weighing me down and i wanted to
sled and so um
i just picked her up and threw her off
the sled and said you're weighing me
down and then i tried to go without she
climbs back on i push her off again and
then i go and sled on my own
this is what parenting's all about okay
sometimes as a parent
you gotta dump the dead weight
that's all just all coyote
run by
anyway um
and then after that we played a game
called king of the mountain where my uh
my my kids would try to climb up the
hill but then i would push them back
down and that was a lot of fun so the
whole thing was a lot of fun it was also
kind of fun to be to work from home
which i haven't done in a while and um
you know yesterday there are some
hiccups though because yesterday i was
you know working in our room and my wife
brought me lunch which is very nice
because she made lunches it was a
sandwich and some chips
and but the thing is at the daily wire
they're also very nice and they provide
us with lunch every single day
and so like a catered lunch and so when
my wife brought me the
uh sandwich and chips i said well thanks
for that but you know with the daily
wire they usually give us an entree and
two sides so
she didn't take kindly to that i don't
know why
just a little bit of constructive
criticism sometimes is what you need in
a marriage i think okay so i have to
play two more clips for you from
yesterday and and
because these are two of the most
egregious
and we'll start with this which is which
is i i think
one of the more egregious lies we've
heard from a politician
i don't know ever and um obviously that
that's really saying something so listen
to nancy pelosi here
let us acknowledge today
as i conclude i want to acknowledge
our fallen heroes of that day
u.s capitol police officer brian siknik
u.s capitol police officer howard living
good
metropolitan officer jeffrey smith
u.s capitol police officer billy evans
of a later assault
now i ask all members to rise for a
moment of silence in their memory
so you heard there from from nancy
pelosi
what you just heard was
every part of that was a total lie but
she really is a decrepit
lying decaying old sack of filth truly
is
she named four officers there who were
she says victims on january 6th but we
lost because of violence on january 6th
and she names brian sicknick jeffrey
smith
howard liebengood and billy evans so
let's review those names for a moment
and um all of them did in fact die
tragically that's very very sad
but sicknick died of a stroke
and there was never confirmed to be any
connection whatsoever between january 6
violence in january 6 and uh sicknick's
stroke
you know there was no substantial
physical uh
internal or external injuries that would
have caused that
so he died of an unrelated medical
emergency
smith and liebengood died days or weeks
later of us of
suicide which again is tragic
um and even more tragic now that it's
that their deaths are being exploited
by people like nancy pelosi and the
media
this is a connection of course the media
made right away when they heard that you
know three weeks later someone who was a
capital police officer died of suicide
and all the headlines were just drawing
this connection
that well clearly he killed himself
because he was traumatized by january 6.
how do you know that
where where are you getting that from
did you take a look at the suicide note
and that's how you know it are you just
assuming this because you want it to be
true because you don't give a damn about
these people the fact that they're dead
and their families are being left behind
what their families are going through
you don't care about that
you're happy that they die you're happy
that they killed themselves because you
can use it
and i know that's the case
because if you weren't happy about it as
something that you could use
um then you wouldn't be you wouldn't be
drawing this connection at all
you don't know anything i mean howard
lieben good to jeffrey smith
you don't know anything about their
lives at all you don't know anything
about what was happening what was going
on in their lives
going on inside them internally in their
minds
there are lots and lots of
anytime a suicide occurs
there are many contributing factors that
that play into it
in someone's life
and for you to stand off a thousand
miles away and say well i'm sure it was
this i'm going to draw a direct
connection between this event that they
were involved in and suicide that is uh
reprehensible it really is
um
and there's also
there's no evidence that the suicides
had anything to do with january 6.
but there are there are some very good
reasons to assume that the
the two things are not connected
and the number one the number one reason
is that again
police officers across the country were
um
subject to violence from rioters for
months and months on end
and there has not been a suicide
epidemic across the country with
officers who are
dealing with rioters
and so when you look at these two cases
what you see are outliers and then the
most logical assumption
is that well they had other things going
on in their lives and in their minds
that led to this tragic outcome
and then what's the the fourth name they
mentioned billy evans
billy evans
was killed
um by violence
but he was killed months later in the
spring
by a leftist farrakhan supporter
and nancy pelosi mentions him too
and you know what the greatest lie of
all of all is
those are some bad lies from nancy
pelosi the greatest lie is that these
people give a damn about dead cops in
the first place because they don't
these are the the only dead cops
that
any
person in the democratic party has ever
cared about
are these capital police officers
because their deaths can be connected to
january 6. well their deaths can't
really be connected to january 6th but
um but the the media the democratic
party are connecting and that's why they
care
biden also uh blatantly lied of course
during his address to the nation calling
it an armed insurrection listen to this
this wasn't a group of tourists
this was an armed insurrection
they weren't looking to uphold the will
of the people they were looking to deny
the will of the people they were looking
uphold they weren't looking uphold a
free and fair election they were looking
to overturn one
they were looking to save
the cause of america
they were looking to subvert the
constitution
this isn't about being bogged down in
the past
it's about making sure the past isn't
buried
that's the only way forward
that's what great nations do
they don't bury the truth
they face up to it sounds like hyperbole
but that's the truth they face up to it
we are a great
nation my fellow americans
in life there's truth
and tragically there are lies
lies conceived and spread
for profit
and
power we must be absolutely clear about
what is true
and what is a lie
he can't accept he lost
even though that's what 93 united states
senators
his own attorney general his own vice
president
governors and state officials in every
battleground state
have all said he lost
that's what 81 million of you did as you
voted for a new way forward
he has done what no president
in american history the history of this
country has ever ever done he refused to
accept the results of an election
and the will of the american people when
you looked at the mob ransacking the
capital
i mean what were they armed with exactly
brochures most of these people were
walking around sightseeing once they got
inside the capitol armed
who are the armed ones
but see this is this is all losing game
anyway um that i said we shouldn't play
and here i am
ranting and raving about it
um it's a it's a losing game when when
uh you know when the left wants to talk
about january 6th and then instead on
the right we spend all of our time
talking about why we're not going to
talk about january 6th because then we
are still talking about it or will we
get into the well it wasn't so bad we
get into this this uh
this back and forth about that about the
how bad it really was and that sort of
thing
um
what we should be doing again go back to
the beginning
we should be redirecting the
conversation
to what actually matters
that would be the blm riots
so we've already done that okay
so from the daily mail it says russia is
to toughen its child sex laws this month
to automatically jail repeat pedophiles
for life in harsh polar prisons
monsters who sexually abuse children
should serve their sentences in hard
labor penal colonies in the arctic where
they could be forced to work in siberian
mines the country's parliamentary
speaker said the new legislation is
being pushed through after a horrific
case this week of a girl five years old
who was abducted by a pedophile repeat
offender and uh then raped and stabbed
to death
and so in russia this is how they
respond they say we know what we're
gonna take these pedophiles now ship
them off to the arctic and use them as
slave labor in arctic mines until they
until they die
this is justice by the way this is what
justice looks like
um you might define justice as as
proportional consequences for your
actions
it's also the most compassionate i think
it's compassionate to victims
of these crimes
where the the perpetrators are given a
consequence that is proportional to the
crime
it is uh compassionate to society
because we're
removing these dangerous people from it
and even if you're concerned about
compassion for the offenders themselves
it's actually the most compassionate for
them
because it's a punishment
this this is the only chance that any
kind of redemption or repentance
um i take a very dim view of of
of you know the chance that that any sex
offender or pedophile could ever
you know be reformed
i don't know that that's even possible
but we have to believe that repentance
at least is possible for everybody at
least theoretically and if there's any
chance of any kind of repentance um it
would require for anybody you know
whatever you've done if you're if you're
ever going to truly repent of it that
requires you to confront
your sin
in and confront
the the true severity of it
and if you've done something like that
then the only way to force this
confrontation is with a punishment with
an extremely harsh punishment
you can't really be sorry for a sin if
you if you are not uh if you're not if
you're not gonna face what you've done
and punishments like this force people
to face uh that's i think it's also true
for the death penalty as well
you know some people say we can't have
the death penalty because in fact that's
this is one of the the so-called
christian arguments because that's
against the death penalty is that uh you
know if you have the death penalty then
you you have removed
you've potentially
taken away an opportunity for someone to
experience repentance and and therefore
redemption and to have a conversion
experience because if you kill them then
that that kind of cuts that short
but i think the opposite is true
because first of all it's not like we're
taking these people the condemned people
and marching them out back as soon as
they've been convicted and um you know
hanging them from the gallows i think
there'd be something to be said for that
approach but that's not what we do so
they've got years and years sometimes
decades in prison
um and that should be plenty of time for
redemption and repentance
but
when
you know when you're given a date of
your death
and you're told you are going to be
executed because of what you've done
then that is a very good opportunity
to actually confront confront the
severity of your sin the darkness of it
and um
because now you're also confronting your
mortality
and then maybe there could be some
repentance okay
now by the way compare this
approach
to sex offenders and pedophiles compare
this to um
to what we do so here's another article
this was published yesterday by the new
york post it says subway pitch man
turned convicted convicted pedophile
jared fogle
has finally showed some remorse for his
crimes
but not really if you keep reading but
it's more about what happened to him
than what he did so that's not remorse
at all
um quote i really royally screwed up to
wind up where i am the father of two
wrote in a handwritten letter dated
november 7th 2021 i was selfish and
entitled
fogel who prosecutors said had 400 child
porn videos in his possession pleaded
guilty in august 2015 to a child
pornography charge and paying for sex
with an underage girl after traveling
from indiana to new york city
and so 400 child porn videos
attempting to rape a child
he says oh i really i really i really
screwed up on that one
this is the first time that fogle now 44
has spoken out about his life behind
bars he wrote that he is inspired by a
line from the movie the shawshank
redemption
he says quote something like you can
either get busy living or get busy dying
when you're sent to prison i've done
everything i can to get busy living and
make the most of this unwanted
experience
fogel who wrote that he thinks that he
thinks quote about all the people i've
let down every single day especially my
my family has a son and a daughter now
eleven and nine
um
and then he goes on to talk about his
prison diet he says that he tries to
avoid junk food he says he snacks on
granola bars and protein bars he says
quote i feel really good physically and
mentally
he says that he exercises a lot quote i
run four to five miles every day i'm the
most healthy and in shape i've ever been
um he says that he he likes to watch tv
uh he spends his free time watching
college and nfl football and he says
that the weekends really fly by and so
he's really not having a bad time at the
end of the day
so this is how we this is a pedophile
at least an attempted child rapist
that's but that's the incident we know
about that he got caught
um it seems very unlikely that's the
only one
so try to rape a child
um child
hundreds and hundreds of videos of of
child pornography
and this is how we rather than shipping
them off to him off to a polar to an
arctic penal colony
he's uh in prison he's snacking on
granola bars he's hanging out he's
watching tv
and though he says he has
he says that there is repentance that
he's sorry
it's very clear that he's not sorry at
all
um he's sorry for letting down his
family
okay that's that's like what you might
say if you get a dui or something like
that
but he has not been forced to confront
the severity of his crimes because this
is what we do with these kinds of
criminals
to let them just hang out in prison for
a few years watch a lot of tv
um and then and then they could go about
their business
all right here's something that's been
making the rounds online
um the video is actually a couple of
years old but it's supposed to show what
online shopping in the metaverse might
look like
and this is what we have this is what
you know we can look forward to this i
guess this is what we have to look
forward to here's uh here's what online
shopping
in in a virtual reality walmart will be
like
great looks like you need a good wine
pairing take a look to your right
your age has already been pre-verified
through your profile so no need to wait
for an id check just place the item in
your cart whenever you're ready
i'm getting a notification from your
connected smart grid
it looks like you already have a full
gallon of milk at home should we put
this one back
hey good news your oil change is done
your vehicle will be ready at the tire
and lube express
so basically all of the worst aspects of
online shopping and real-life shopping
is what you get from there
how
we've taken all the bad things about
both strategies
none of the benefits
so i'm just wondering how is that an
improvement on like regular online
shopping as it stands right now
how is it who when you're when you're
you know on a website ordering food or
something like that
who says to themselves well this is
pretty convenient but i wish that i was
inside this website so that i could
rather than moving over and just
clicking on what i want i have to
pretend to walk over to it on
fake shelves in a fake grocery store and
grab it with my fake hand who says that
what
what's the advantage there exactly
but what i think what i think you really
really see from this because this is um
you know this is not the only example of
the metaverse that we've we've seen
jeff zuckerberg has provided some
examples of his vision of the metaverse
and what what facebook will be in the
future
i think what you really see is that we
are as a society
creatively exhausted
that this is the best we can come up
with
virtual reality technology
i mean think about
30 years ago when people imagined the
possibility of virtual reality
technology
and um you know what a future might be
like when this becomes ubiquitous
and then compare that to
to the to the reality of virtual reality
so we we have we have this technology
and now we're just
creating
um
fassimals mills we're we're creating
carb copies
of our normal everyday
dreary experiences
i mean why online shopping in virtual
reality why would you create a virtual
reality version of walmart
if we're gonna do it then why not look
on how about it's a walmart on mars
or something
and there's and there's there are
dragons flying around
anything but you use use your
imagination
what is the advantage of of virtual
reality
where it's simply a copy of actual
reality
but slightly creepier
um finally i'm sorry that i have to tell
you about this but i do it's my
obligation a social media influencer
named stephanie mato has been raising
tens of thousands of dollars selling her
farts in a jar this is a real thing
and if you're wondering about the ins
and outs of this business here she is
explaining it
hey guys today i'm gonna be showing you
a day in the life of a girl who sells
her farts in a jar so i like to get
things rolling with some beans a protein
muffin sometimes even a yogurt less
sugar is better
some hard-boiled eggs and today i
decided i was going to make myself a
protein shake with some yogurt added to
it and oh i was feeling it for sure
while i wait for those parts to develop
i like to read i'm very smart love to
read and then after i'm ready to go i go
ahead and you know do my work do my job
i don't need to show you that guys but i
like to add in little flower petals i
feel like they attach the scent and make
it last longer and when i'm finally
finished with my jar i like to leave a
personalized note i want to thank you so
much the 97 people who have already
purchased their jar of farts and as you
know they're on sale right now fifty
percent off of one thousand dollars so
go to my unfiltered and check it
well you know that's one way to earn
some gas money
i guess a guy who buys uh one of the
jars is a man after her own fart
but look i mean she did build this
business from the ground up and that's
good because sometimes you just have to
fart from scratch
sorry i'm done maybe anyway tragedy has
struck and uh this is the latest update
about stephanie she apparently she's now
out of the farts selling game this is
from metro news that says a former
90-day fiance star has
made a staggering 38 000 a week from
selling her farts in a jar
but now she's revealed that she was
rushed to the hospital
uh stephanie mato recently shed light on
her unusual stream of income explaining
how she utilized her 260 000 strong
following
as her customer base to sell her pungent
product
but now she says that after a medical
incident she has to get out of business
entirely
it says she may have squeezed out one
too many as the reality star had to make
a hospital dash she told jam press quote
i thought i was having a stroke and that
these were my final moments i was
overdoing it
she recalled that she consumed three
protein shakes and a huge bowl of black
bean soup in one day before feeling that
something quote was not right with a
pressure in her stomach that moved up
through her body she thought she was
having a heart attack and now her
doctors have advised her to stop doing
this so that's the end of her business
but you know maybe she'll start it back
up at a later date
and that'll be good maybe because
you know what they say
absence makes the fart grow fonder
i said i was done i had to do one more
sorry
now time for the comment sections
[Music]
days of noah says my ex-wife had
multiple personality syndrome when she
went to the psychiatrist he charged her
the group rate
well
i had to throw that in there as well
well done days of noah
uh we're doing the dead we're in the car
we've got the dad jokes going
[Music]
spencer says matt needs to convince the
dw to make his set look like he's
podcasting from a car get the best of
both worlds high quality production with
car cast nostalgia we actually
considered that a few years ago we
talked about really doing that building
a set in a studio that looks like a car
and uh we decided not to do the in the
end probably for the best
uh snow aboard says i wonder if matt did
his own makeup today he claims his
producer does it but if he's the only
one in the car doesn't that make him the
producer and thus the makeup culprit
no in fact my wife did my makeup so
which is a sentence that i wish i had
not said out loud but i did my wife did
my makeup
i'm sure when she got married some 10
years ago this is what she dreamed of is
that one day she'd be able to do her
husband's makeup before he goes outside
in a snowstorm to do a podcast in his
car these are these are the moments that
she dreamt of as a as a young a young
bride
um
history at headlines says have you ever
interacted with anybody with multiple
personalities no because that doesn't
exist and that's why i've never
interacted with somebody like that
and brandon says as a psychiatrist
professional your concept of did is spot
on we're seeing trends in some hospital
settings from adolescents presenting
with rare conditions tic toc has been
brought up many times during the
diagnostic interviews
uh
yeah that's that's
we see how social media again is a is a
is a factory for these kinds of social
contagions
and um
did dissociative identity disorder is
just one example iridescent one says
thank you for talking about the
self-diagnosis issue on tick-tock it's
not just did either kids are faking
having tourette's autism bipolar
personality disorders i have to wonder
if parents had any knowledge about what
their children do on social media
whether half of this would disappear
overnight if they did
they probably don't
and that's because when you're when you
set your child free into cyberspace it's
actually very difficult to keep track of
what they're doing and to keep track of
all of the images and ideas that they're
being exposed to which is why
i always say
keep your kid off the internet
don't give them a phone with access to
the internet
and you could solve all of these
problems very easily that way today is a
massive day for the daily wire and even
bigger for america today the supreme
court will convene to hear arguments on
the legality and constitutionality of
biden's vaccine mandates that's why we
need to ask one last time for you to
sign our do not comply petition as we
can send a very important message
americans will not comply with tyranny
we have over 1 million signatures
already we need your help with this so
go to dailywire.com
do not comply and sign the petition now
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're gonna have a quick
cancellation uh so that i don't freeze
to death out here it's about 10 degrees
outside and i'm somewhat regretting my
decision to record a podcast in a car
but you know this is at least better
than the old days of the car cast when
sometimes it was summer if it was summer
and i would i would be out in the car
when it's 90 degrees
and i'm baking a live on camera
so
for for both safety and comfort i would
recommend that if you're considering
podcasting from your car wait for mild
weather conditions better yet don't
podcast from your car at all because
this is just kind of weird on top of it
all but anyway today i'm going to cancel
country star morgan wallin
now wallin you probably recall was
canceled several months ago
after a a neighbor secretly recorded him
as he was outside his house drunk
and uh he used the n-word once in a
joking way towards his white friend
and the video of this drunken banter was
sent to the media and then they took the
opportunity to try and ruin wallen's
life and career
um because why not but their plot failed
the daily wire has the latest it says
despite being banned by award shows
suspended by his label dropped by his
agent and having his songs pulled from
radio stations and music streaming
platforms morgan wallin has still
managed to score 2021's top album in any
genre according to billboard's year-end
report to the shock of the music
industry fans stood by him after his
cancellation and dangerous the double
album which had been released only weeks
before continued to climb the charts now
that the end of year tallies have come
in billboard reported wallen's record um
wrapped up the year with 3.2 million
equivalent album units earned in the u.s
most that total was derived from
streaming downloads of the album's list
of 30 songs the outlet also noted that
dangerous is the first country album to
top the yearly chart since taylor
swift's 2009 release fearless
okay so they tried to cancel him but
instead wallen turned around and simply
became the best-selling recording artist
in all genres over the past year
so why am i canceling him then
why after surviving his cancellation
attempt would i turn around and cancel
him anyway
he defeated cancel culture didn't he
isn't that a good thing
that's exactly the point
many on the right have celebrated
wallen's story as an example of somebody
vanquishing cancel culture but he didn't
because you can't defeat cancel culture
after you've already groveled and
apologized
wallin immediately after the video was
published
apologized repeatedly over and over
again he apologized and written
statements he apologized in video
statements he apologized in interviews
the fact that he went on to have the
best-selling album of the year only
proves that the apology wasn't necessary
the fans aren't buying his music because
he apologized
uh they're not saying oh you know he
apologized so it means it's okay to
listen to his songs now they're buying
his music because they don't care about
the
vulgarity he used jokingly to a friend
while he was drunk outside his house
the fans don't care about that
no normal person cares about that
no rational person ever cared about it
the media cared they wanted the public
to care the
public didn't care and still doesn't
and that's why he's gone on and to have
a the most successful album and they're
listening to the music anyway
now this doesn't vindicate wallen's
response to his cancellation
it only proves once again why he didn't
need to respond that way
he thought he was in a pr crisis and
apologizing was the only way out but
there was no pr crisis a pr crisis
requires the public's involvement but
the public didn't care
the public didn't need an apology
the public was in no way harmed by a
word that wallen drunkenly used to his
friend
nobody was harmed
that's one of the reasons why the public
apology genre needs to go away because
in a public apology you're apologizing
to people who were not at all affected
by your infraction
what's the point of that
well i know the point
it's ritual self-humiliation
and that's a game that wallen thought he
needed to play but he didn't
so so what have we learned about cancer
culture we've learned that the media the
media directs cancel culture you know
they're the drivers of it
they're the conductors
but in order for someone to actually be
fully and successfully canceled it
requires one of two things one the
cooperation of the public you know the
public needs to be convinced that the
cancelled person really is an evil
scumbag and deserves to be exiled from
society or two
the cooperation of the cancelled person
the canceled person needs to go along
with their own cancellation submit to it
offer themselves as a sacrifice on the
altar
yet the public very rarely cares about
the latest outrage as much as the media
wants them to and even when they do care
they always stop caring after a few days
because nobody remembers anything for
more than a few days
so that means that most cancellations
involve number two they involve the
cooperation of the cancelee
and he's cooperating for no reason
he could simply tell his cancelers to
screw off
and he'd be fine
yet he apologized anyway
so for the umpteenth time
stop apologizing morgan wallin's case
is proof that you don't need to
apologize
just could tell cancer culture to kiss
your ass and live your life
but he didn't do that
he could have but he didn't
and that's why he is ultimately
by me anyway
cancelled
and uh we'll leave it there and i'm
gonna go inside and chip the ice off my
toes i'll talk to you on monday
hopefully and a real studio once again
have a great weekend
godspeed
[Music]
well if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe and if you want to
help spread the word please give us a
five star review also tell your friends
to subscribe as well we're available on
apple podcast spotify wherever you
listen to podcasts we're there also be
sure to check out the other daily wire
podcasts including the ben shapiro show
michael knowles show the andrew clavin
show thanks for listening the matt wall
show is produced by sean hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadowsky the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
matt wall show us the daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin